the new trade policy in a White House
staff shake-up show President Trump is
moving toward a more aggressive foreign
policy his new national security adviser
john bolton who's replacing HR McMaster
has advocated military action against
American foes and the president's
tariffs against Chinese imports are
provoking a strong reports a strong
response rather from Beijing but it's
all taking place as a president's past
personal life is coming front and center
we're talking about the president and a
former Playboy model this morning we are
this morning a former Playboy model is
speaking out about her alleged affair
with President Trump before he took
office Karen McDougal described an
alleged relationship in her first TV
interview McDougal is one of two women
seeking to free themselves from legal
agreements so that they can speak freely
about alleged affairs with the president
the other is adult film star stormy
Daniels Paula Reed is at the White House
with the latest Paula good morning good
morning
McDougal shared intimate details about
her relationship with the president but
this could get her in legal trouble if a
judge finds that this interview violated
the agreement she made not to talk about
that relationship I need to share my
story speaking with Anderson Cooper
former Playboy model Karen McDougal
revealed details of her alleged 10 month
affair with President Trump which she
says began in summer 2006 after we had
been in cement he he tried to pay me and
I actually didn't know how to take that
did he actually try to hand you money he
did mcdougal says she was attracted to
Trump even in love but admits she
doesn't have much evidence to support
her story if you're in a loving
relationship do you try and collect
evidence
she says she ended the relationship in
2007 out of guilt and now has this
message for the first lady what can you
say except I'm sorry I'm sorry
I wouldn't want it done to me on Tuesday
mcdougal filed a lawsuit against
American media incorporated demanding
she be released from a 2016 legal
agreement that she says effectively
silenced her from speaking out about the
alleged relationship she alleges Trump's
personal attorney Michael Cohen was
secretly involved in the deal making I
feel like the contract is illegal I feel
like I wasn't presented correctly am i
responded to the suit saying mcdougal
has been free to respond to press
inquiries about her relationship with
President Trump since 2016 adult film
star stormy daniel says she also had an
affair with the president CBS News
obtained a letter her lawyer sent to the
Trump Organization on Thursday it
demands the company preserve its records
relating to a 130 thousand dollar
payment Daniel's received as part of a
nondisclosure agreement that Cohen
negotiated Daniel's attorney cites
unmistakable links that mr. Trump's
company was involved in a transaction
before the 2016 presidential election a
lawyer for Michael Cohen calls that
letter quote frivolous and says he's
confident that that lawsuit will be
thrown out both Cohen and the White
House continue to deny that the
president had relationships with either
one of these women but a watchdog group
has asked the Justice Department and the
FEC to look into that hundred and fifty
thousand dollars MacDougall received as
a possible illegal campaign contribution
viana Paula so much to untangle there
thank you and a reminder you can watch
stormy Daniels interview with Anderson
Cooper Sunday on 60 minutes this is the
first and only television interview in
which Daniel speaks about the alleged
relationship that is Sunday here on CBS
must watch television yes I'll be there
with a bowl of popcorn H is so tawdry
that the president a porn star a Playboy
model and all I keep thinking about
really is Melania Trump yeah this is all
unfolding in such a public way for her
and to hear the former lovers say I want
to apologize to her that's not what you
want to hear I want you to stop talking
about is what I'm thinking
yeah from her point of view